on va parler maintenant du dossier du
jour et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a
tous été on a pris un coup sur la tête
avec ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui on a
tous des infos on les a eus je crois que
vous avez eu les cerner der au téléphone
nicholas boys le dossier du jour
concerne gérard gérard louvin grand
producteur de télévision très connu
mieux mais c'était essais c'était à
l'époque
et d'ailleurs on travaille toujours un
peu gérard maintenant il vit l'arrêter
mais c'était le plus grand producteur
jeu de tf1 tf1 c'était le taulier les
producteurs à sacrée soirée deux des
plus gros émission de julien c'est lui
qui a lancé julien courbet qui a lancé
jean-pierre champion des lancements et
qui a lancé plein d'autres personnes
baril est attaquée en justice par son
neveu olivier pour des faits de viols
alors qu'il était âgé de 10 ans dans
cette plainte le mari du rhin en vain
daniel moyne est également accusé les
accusations de viol et d'inceste du
neveu de gérard louvin ont fait
énormément parler aujourd'hui
1 c'est sorti dans le monde ce matin
dans un instant va tout vous expliquer
qui est gérard lanvin qui est daniel
moyne de quoi sont-ils accusés on aura
bien sûr les deux avocats avec nous
petit récap pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas voici qui élira ou 20 et ce qu'il a
fait au cours de sa carrière et ses
intérêts qu il était chroniqueur chez
nous pendant trois saisons
gérard louvin vos côtés d'ailleurs
isabelle cette année il est c'est la
seule qui a connu gérard dans l'émission
d'hier et avant dans beaucoup de
reportages on a fait plusieurs
opérations ensemble quand j'étais gérard
il était chroniqueur avec nous c'est
toujours ça détruit tout ah mais oui
j'ai des rapports de franche amitié avec
lui alors c'est vrai que cette affaire
elle nous a tous bouleversés
voilà et vous aurez dans un instant bien
entendu on aura la version dont de
gérard louvin et de daniel moyne via
leurs avocats puisqu'ils seront tous les
deux avec nous regardez petit récap
télévision comédie musicale cinéma aux
boys band gérard louvin est un véritable
homme d'affaires en près de cinquante
ans de carrière le producteur et ancien
chroniqueur de tpm paix est à l'origine
de quelques uns des shows les plus
mythiques de ces dernières décennies y
avait pas une émission qui se faisait
sans l'aval de gérard louvin
parmi elles on retrouve entre autres
sacrée soirée ciel mon mardi ou encore
sans aucun doute il participera à
plusieurs émissions comme la star
academy en tant que directeur du château
on n'demande qu'à en rire en tant que
jury ou encore tpm paix en tant que
chroniqueur et quand on pense gérard
louvin on pense aussi à la comédie
musicale roméo et juliette qui produit
en 2001
le rock c'est lui aussi qui sera à
l'origine de la création de nombreux
groupes mythiques des années 90 qui
feront danser toute la france
et gérard louvin aussi il était
producteur de la star ac
la star ac 4 qui résume bien sa carrière
puisque on va regarder un portrait dire
à un mouvement qui avait été fait lors
de sa star ac 4 et regarder gérard
louvin isaïe fait un portrait de lui
bien sûr et c'est vrai que si c est
normal gérard aujourd'hui voilà c'est
c'est eh puis d'étayer c'est vrai qu'il
a eu plein d'idées c'est une appli à me
plaindre une qualité c'est un binôme un
gerald howarth daniel moyne ils ont
vraiment travaillé jamais ressenti ce
jour là chez darty statique et éloignées
gérard était producteur regarde je
m'appelle gérard louvin ça fait plus de
trente ans que je suis producteur 14
films 48 spectacle 2000 émission de
télévision j'ai côtoyé environ 3000
artistes
j'ai aidé à grandir les artistes d'un
chanteur florent pagny michel lahaye
pierre palmade maxime anthony kavanagh
est mon ami jean-pierre foucault je
viens d'un milieu modeste j'étais
cuisinier j'étais maître d'hôtel j'étais
ambulanciers et un jour j'ai rencontré
claude françois que j'ai appris avec cet
artiste et tous les artistes que j'ai
côtoyés que le doute faisait partie de
la vie des artistes ne faut pas hésiter
à douter un artiste doute toujours le
matin quand ils se lèvent le soir quand
il se couche
gérard louvin généralement avec une
phrase aussi qui dit il faut dix ans
pour être connu du jour au lendemain on
va voir qui est daniel mois d'un dans un
instant puisque dans la plonge dans la
plainte un autre nom cité celui daniel
moyne le conjoint de gérard louvin
depuis plus de 45 ans nicolas pernikoff
oui bien sûr moi je les connais depuis
plus de trente ans donc j'ai connu moi
j'ai des variances métier j'avais 18 ans
donc d'ailleurs tout le monde et est un
peux même vous enlevez les enfants de la
télé ont tous connu gérard louvin gerald
ou un traité sur le premier à inventer
un peu les shows paillettes et ont le
coeur à l'époque voilà f1 bien sûr l'aï
bien sûr donc n'avait patron des
divertissements de tf1 exactement on va
revenir sur cette affaire dans un
instant bus qu'on aura les deux avocats
qui seront avec nous de gérard louvin et
daniel moyne ils vont nous donner leurs
versions verrez de quoi ils sont accusés
puisque tout le monde en a parlé
aujourd'hui
et puis on aura natalia la maman de
youri qui revient sur la soirée qui a
brisé leur vie c'est un fait divers qui
a créé une énorme vague d'indignation
tout le week-end dans toute la france et
sa maman parlera pour la première fois
en plateau dans touche pas à mon poste
ce sera dans un instant à tout de suite
mais suite merci d'être aussi nombreux à
nous regarder dans un instant on aura
natalia la maman de youri qui reviendra
sur sa soirée sur la soirée qui a brisé
leur vie
et il y aura son beau-père le beau père
de youri qui sera avec elle c'est
vraiment que ça vient de tomber sont
venus tous les deux parce qu'ils
voudraient s'exprimer également c'est la
première fois qu'il s'exprimera la télé
c'est la première fois que la maman du
riz natalia sera sur un plateau de
télévision elle a choisi de venir nous
raconter toute cette affaire et nous
donner aussi des nouvelles de youri pour
savoir dans quel état il est pour le
moment on est on parle de du producteur
et c'est vrai que c'est voilà il était
avec nous et on s'est toujours très bien
entendu avec gérard main quand il était
dans l'émission on a passé des moments
avec lui exceptionnel on va pas se
mentir
isabelle morini-bosc vrai que voilà on a
fait les fous rires à quoi bon a vécu
des moments fous avec lui et aujourd'hui
gérard louvin il a une plainte contre
lui contre son mari daniel moyne
accusations de viol et d'inceste de son
neveu qui ont beaucoup fait parler
aujourd'hui c'était en top tweets toute
la journée tout le monde bien sûr on a
parlé tous les sites médias ont repris
cette information qui est parue dans le
monde aujourd'hui et on a la chance
d'avoir m céline bekerman merci mais
d'être là avec m christophe ayela vous
êtes tous les deux vous êtes l'avocat de
daniel moyne daniel moyne exactement
donc le conjoint de gérard louvin et
vous christophe ayela vous êtes l'avocat
de gérard louvin voile alors on va
revenir sur toute la sphère ont déjà on
va voir de quoi et sont accusés gérard
louvin et daniel moyne regarde
le producteur gérard louvin est
actuellement dans la tourmente il faut
aujourd'hui la une de l'actualité suite
à une plainte déposée par son neveu pour
complicité de viol sur mineur de moins
de 15 ans aujourd'hui âgé de 48 ans
olivier qui se trouve être le fils de la
soeur de gérard louvin accuse le
producteur de complicité liés à des
attouchements sexuels de la part de
daniel moyne le mari de gérard louvin
lorsqu'il avait entre 10 et 14 ans en
2007 déjà olivier avait alerté la police
accusant les deux hommes d'attouchements
sur leur fils adoptif cette fois ci à
l'époque la justice n'avait pas donné
suite en raison de la prescription des
faits supposés de son côté gérard louvin
répond à ces accusations et dénonce une
tentative d'extorsion de fonds une
affaire qui fait suite au mouvement mitu
inceste initié par les révélations
autour du politologue olivier duhamel
ce soir les avocats de gérard louvin m
ayela maîtres bekerman sont avec nous
olivier a donc 48 ans porté plainte le 8
janvier dernier contre son oncle gérard
lanvin et daniel moyne le mari gérard
louvin pour viol sur mineur de moins de
15 ans par ascendant complicité de viol
sur mineur de moins de 15 ans par
ascendant et corruption de mineurs merci
à vous d'être là qu'est-ce qu'il va
répondre à ces accusations
est ce que vous voulez commencer être
bekerman aucun problème je dirais dans
un premier temps que daniel moyne comme
gérard louvin sont consternés par la
violence de telle accusation qu'il
réfute complètement donc là dans votre
présentation
vous évoquez la sphère duhamel ça n'a
strictement rien à voir on est face à
quelqu'un
face à des personnes qui conteste les
accusations ce qui n'est pas l'occasion
à faire du zèle
déjà c'est une différence est majeure
christophe écoutez je viens parler pour
gérard louvin je viens porter une parole
qui me semble nécessaire parce que quand
vous êtes accusé aujourd'hui dans un
article de presse à grand tirage vous
êtes quasiment condamné c'est bien de
nous laisser nous exprimer merci pour ça
parce qu'on a beaucoup de choses à dire
sur la défense de gérard louvin qui le
méritent totalement ce qu'on voudrait
dire c'est que cette affaire est très
curieuse c'est extrêmement bizarre de
voir que vous avez une personne qui a
vécu régulièrement avec gérard louvin
depuis plus de trente ans depuis sa
majorité je veux il était et il était
très proche et il était proche ils
s'envoyaient gérard louvin a toujours
répondu aux demandes de
date de services qu'aux régulièrement
ils recevaient de son neveu depuis plus
de 30 ans gérard n'a jamais reculé vous
dis non
il a toujours été très proche de lui ce
neveu qui lui demandait de temps en
temps des services s'ils en recevaient
ils ont travaillé ensemble ou pas du
tout j'ajouterai qu'il a travaillé sur
toutes les émissions que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure les sacrée soirée
tout l'entourage de gérard louvin
connaissons ne veux mon nikon ont
travaillé ensemble pendant des années et
partez ensemble en vacances alors vous
allez me dire ça prouve rien oui ce que
je suis pas sûr qu'une victime puisque
c'est des faits qui sont supposés oui si
on écoute la victime remontait quand
même il ya très longtemps continue à
passer ses vacances avec la personne
présumée de son agresseur il ya quand
même quelque chose d'étrange
par exemple pour encore faire un
parallèle avec la sphère duhamel on voit
bien que la victime a coupé contact
arrêtez d'aller à sanary et là on est
dans un cas de figure où la vraie
victime présumée bien entendu continuer
revient régulièrement en vacances alors
il s'agit par une fois de plus faut
toujours parler avec énormément de
précautions dans ses affaires sur ce que
la parole de la victime présumée est
importante
et d'ailleurs si si si les avocats de la
victime veulent venir on en parlait il
ya aucun souci également y est enfin
c'est normal que le procès sera devant
des tribunaux si un hypothèse est peu
probable mais non mais vous trouvez que
le procès il a déjà été fait là par là
c'est le sait le tribunal du voeu c'est
la vindicte populaire c'est tout les
twitter qui se déchaînent qui sont en
train de traiter
gérard louvin de pédophile gérard moine
daniel moyne de pédophiles c'est une
honte
c'est une honte tant que la justice ne
s'est pas prononcée il faut quand même
rappeler à tout le monde et surtout aux
téléspectateurs que gérard louvin et
daniel moyne sont résumées innocent
alors c'est pas m m à yahia alors donc
gérard louvin qu'est-ce qui lui
reprochent son neveu il lui reproche
quoi et qu'elle est ce qu'elle est c'est
à dire qu'elle est la défense de gira il
rapproché déjà vous l'avais dit dans
votre sujet en 2006 d'avoir soi disant
eu des contacts avec son propre fils
affaire classée
hilare reprocher son propre fils de
gérard voilà c'était déjà d'accord déjà
c'est une totale faire acter que
l'affairé a été classée ac après encore
donc c'est son neveu qu'avec avait déjà
attaqué
on était alors vous avez ensuite en 2015
une personne qui refait un signalement à
la police d'accord c'est quand pendant
un an
affaire classée concernant concernant le
même fait qu'aujourd'hui d'accord alors
et qui revient à la charge
plusieurs années plus tard 2015 2020
vous avez donc olivier qui revient donc
l'auto poussière à laudun et voilà tu
reviens son neveu pour faire quoi pour
demander de l'argent en faisant du
chantage donc et c'est l'argent donc là
votre version de la version duras loin
c'est que son neveu est revenu à la
charge et nous voir gérard louvin pour
lui demander de l'argent ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines ces
dernières semaines vous avez à faire
donc de plus en plus de demandes de
demandes de demandes puisque dans
l'esprit on le voit dans l'article de
presse de ce matin dans l'esprit
d'olivier gérard quelqu'un de très
fortunés très médiatique très connue
donc il doit lui donner de l'argent de
plus en plus d'argent et gérard louvin
dit non donc il a dit non il ya quelques
semaines quelques semaines de façon très
ferme très clair très net il lui a dit
non je ne donnerai pas je ne cèderai pas
un chantage et j'ai demandé combien 768
d'euros 750 mille ou 700 euros d'abord
nous avons un document
c'est pas tout le temps le cas mais là
nous avons un document qui de la main
d'olivier qui dit quoi qui en attestent
par lequel il réclame cette somme écrit
de sa propre main d'accord il y qui lui
réclame 700 hydro sinon il va faire des
révélations aussi nous il va raconter
des c koi même c'est quand même un peu
plus habile oui c'est vrai dire c'est un
peu plus subtil
c'est moi j'ai souffert alors sans que
ce soit très clair sur les faits qui
sont reprochés parce que de toute façon
ces faits ne sont pas établis
il lui dit clairement soit vous me
donnez 700000 euros et puis on pourra
continuer à partir en vacances et
s'amuser comme des fous et faire
sieffert cela soit ça va mal aller et
évidemment par les temps qui courent il
savait que sa parole aurait un
probablement plus de points d'accord
donc
donc moi j'invite vraiment tout le monde
à réfléchir à ce qui se passe là dans
cette affaire la pad amalgames il a des
vraies victimes
ça existe on sait mais dans cette
affaire là je demande à tout le monde de
bien prendre le temps de lire de
réfléchir avant d'accuser parce que il
dit se désister extrêmement de leur site
les autres victimes alors dans le don
dans le monde via le témoignage
d'olivier et de sa mère donc la soeur de
gérard louvin dans le monde
il raconte que c'est gérard louvin qui
lui a appris à bien se tenir à table à
nager lors de vacances en corse
lorsqu'il est has avait une dizaine
d'années il était invité par le couple a
passé quelques week-ends dans leur
appartement de boulogne billancourt dont
gérard louvin et daniel moyne c'est là
que les choses auraient commencé voilà
ce qu'il raconte daniel est allongé à
côté de moi avec ses caresses il
réveille mon corps je peux le dire
aujourd'hui j'ai une érection
je découvre ça c'est mécanique il doit
sentir ça prends ma main
voilà il a mais il est là il me montre
comment voilà je ne sais pas tout ça je
ne sais plus si c'est ce soir là où il
met ma tête tout est arrivés petit à
petit c'est plutôt silencieux dont qui
il décrit vraiment il est il est assez
précis dans dance kids écrit et dont il
dit dans l'article l'article du monde
c'est ce qu'on voit comment comment
aujourd'hui on peut être aussi précis et
aller voir un un journal assez sérieux
le monde pour faire un témoignage alors
qu'on alors que pour vous il mentir et
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à ses
détracteurs qui lance aujourd'hui déjà
nous avons la conviction qu'il est
manipulé par un tiers qu'on n'a pas
identifiés jusqu'à présent d'accord mais
il peut pas avoir pris seul l'initiative
d'une telle action dépit de toute façon
c'est même pas sa façon de parler
quand vous regardez par exemple le
document dans lequel il réclame 700
mille euros et la manière dont il est
rédigé et vous regardez ensuite
l'article du monde où les différents
courriers électroniques qui ont pu être
reçus dans cette affaire vous voyez bien
qu'il ya quelqu'un derrière tout ça
qui c'est un grand mystère mais on va
bien finir par savoir puisqu'il un
avocat aussi épais elle survole je suis
un avocat il a un avocat il a neuf le
cas puisqu'il est cité dans le monde son
avocat il a même participé à l'interview
du monde a donc jusqu'au bout des
avocats
contre leur client pour jeu la pure
calomnie dans les médias et qui ne se
cache plus ce qu'il faut même davantage
que sap vous avez des avocats qui
peuvent accompagner aussi des clients
comme c'est le cas là sont des demandes
financières sont du chantage
moi j'ai une passion en place gérard
louvin et daniel moyne dans une
situation impossible sert comment voulez
prouver quelque chose qui selon eux n'a
pas existé
c'est une preuve négative ils font
comment ils font comme en face et à ces
accusations pour se défendre alors j'ai
une question à vous poser parce que on
passa dans la partie j'ai une petite
question posée je pense que tout le
monde a la même question que moi c'est
parti m bekerman et m
elle est là pourquoi il s'est réveillé
maintenant pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé non mais c'est vrai pourquoi
pourquoi ça a mis tant de temps et
pourquoi est ce que parce que je vous
dis la question que l'on se pose c'est
est-ce que gérard humains et daniel
monde aurait voilà il y aurait l'aurait
aidé pendant toutes ces années peut-être
qu'ils ont arrêté deux refusé de l'aider
il s'est dit bon bah je vais révéler des
choses ou bien je vais révéler des
choses vrai ou pas vrai voilà on saura
après si c'est vrai ou pas vrai on
espère que c'est faux bien entendu
projet en mai comment comment ça
pourquoi il a mis ton temps alors une
idée qui m'est venue en lisant l'article
de presse de ce matin ce qui est
frappant c'est que le dit avoir déposé
une plainte le 8 janvier oui la veille
de ses 48 ans mais est donc je pense que
aiguiller ou mal conseillé aussi il
pensait qu'il pouvait en réalité déposé
plainte la veille de ses 48 heures
puisque ça faisait 30 ans que ses 18 ans
ah d'accord
voilà pourquoi il a accéléré ses
demandes financières sous menace de
déposer une plainte et de calomnie parce
qu'il pensait que ce serait trop tard
d'accord où il a été influencé par la
terrible et triste affaire duhamel mais
c'est également une possibilité
est ce que est ce que vous pensez parce
que c'est ce que vous vous dire aussi
moi je me fais l'avocat voit là aussi
l'avocat du diable et de ce qui se passe
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
plein de gens qui disent est ce qu'une
personne qui n'est pas sûre de ce
qu'elle dit et qui a montré des choses
iraient jusqu'à les porter plainte et
irait jusqu'à s'adresser au monde
vraiment avec un tel aplomb l'a déjà
fait 6
déjà fait en 2015 il ya eu des
négociations
en 2015 il a été entendu par la police
déjà sonné ça n'était pas sorti en 2015
ce n'est pas sorti parce qu'il y ait une
enquête sérieuse d'accord qu'il n'a pas
parlé aux journaux aux médias ou autre
et que l' enquête a conclu qu'il n'y
avait pas lieu à penser pourquoi on
ressort pas l'anc est aujourd'hui une
enquête qui a été fait en 2015 c'est ça
qui ont que je me pose comme question à
cette façon-là travailler avec
christophe et on va sortir au fur et à
mesure tous les éléments et parce que
l'on tienne 2015 elle a été quoi la
conclusion c'était sur les mêmes faits
céder sur l'événement s'est ensuite les
mêmes faits lehmann fait donc il avait
fait le même témoignage en 2015
un d'eux mêmes témoignages la police
d'accord à l'époque gérard louvin a été
entendu monsieur mois n'a été entendu la
police a conclu avec le prendre le
procureur de paris qui avait pas lieu
aller plus loin moi si vous voulez vous
avez une personne qui non seulement ne
réitère pas sa plainte après 2016 alors
que ça fait cinq ans mais qui en plus
aujourd'hui sous prétexte de demander de
l'argent
vacallo billets dans les médias parce
qu'on l'appelle pas d'accord donc vous
dire qu'ils se sont revus après s'être
plaint de 2015 la sarkozie tout le temps
dans le temps ça lui a porté plainte
deux sens entre 2015 et 2020 je parle de
la période 2015 et 2021
ils se sont revus régulièrement il s'est
échangé des sms
c'était en compta c'est pour ça que
gérard louvin est tombé de sa chaise le
plus triste dans cette affaire c'est que
gérard louvin aimait son neveu daniel
moyne pareil c'était la famille fait
pour les ce2 ou les a vus forcément
aujourd'hui sont dans quelle étagère à
l'autre et ils sont aguerris aux
discours abassourdi hier abat son
discernement de porter cette parole
comporte aussi dans les médias
aujourd'hui de dire c'est pas vrai c'est
pas parce que c'est le tournant et en
accenter également aux avocats du
plaignant
si vous voulez venir s'exprimer et n'ont
pas souhaité s'exprimer ni le plaignant
ni ni ses avocats
voilà je vous dis sur cette affaire donc
on va voir s'ils veulent s'exprimer dans
les prochains jours pour l'instant il ne
souhaite pas le faire oui j'ai une
deuxième question pourquoi il n'a pas
porté plainte parce que quand lens est
simplement de 700000 euros d amende et
moi je flippe je veux dire cette famille
aussi quand même beaucoup d'argent donc
rico où ils ont à porter plainte à ce
moment là
le chantage quand même c'est le remède
est pire que le mal est ce que c est ce
que ça les faisait droit à pension à
partager justement de donner la plainte
le pen c'est que vous donnez de la
publicité à une affaire qui est close
depuis 2007 s'est terminé l'état donc
les veaux déposerait plainte pour
extorsion restant sur l'extorsion et
fait donner un permis cités affaire qui
finalement est terminée qua non parce
que je sais que ça ira loin s'est dit
sisi je vais porter plainte certaines
pontes de l'ampleur et au contraire ça
va lui raisonnée surtout enfin résonner
son talent mais qui est ce qui va porter
plainte aujourd'hui
la plainte sera déposée avant la fin de
la semaine pour tentative d'extorsion de
fonds bon alors a priori ce sera de ce
chef chantage tout ça il faut qu'on
détermine les dénonciations calomnieuses
pour l'arctique de smara évidemment
benjamin pourquoi l'après-2015 daniel et
gérard on continue à parler à ceux à ce
n'est pas ce que c'est quand même grave
c'est ça dont on m'accuse un truc et
c'est vrai table je le franchement je
passe pas les brosses à dents après lui
faire une personne qui se dit enfin j'ai
dit et je sais pas ce que je fais dit
elle-même toxicomane depuis très
longtemps et gravement et c'est vers moi
donc c'est une personne qui a besoin de
quelques fragilités que peut-être
tendance a aussi incertaine mythomanie
je ne sais mais en tout cas y'a bon
cette enquête culture s est terminée et
on se reparle
et finalement on va pas lui fermer la
porte on va parler de or monsieur
olivier et tony gré d'après les
informations qui ont été communiquées
par le journaliste du monde
oui alors qu'elle était informée de ce
qui était reproché à son frère et à son
beau-frère déjà à continuer à travailler
le gérard louvin et ne s'est manifesté
que très récemment en disant ça y est je
suis aux côtés de mon fils la soeur ne
parle plus à gérard louvin ce qui est
encore une blessure supplémentaire
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre pour
répondre à la question de tout à l'heure
c'est que gérard louvin pourquoi vous me
dites pourquoi il n'a pas porté plainte
c'était son neveu ils adorent et son
neveu je ne veux laver ma mère se ne
venait pas de perth et gérard louvin qui
s'est comporté comme son père toute sa
vie qu'il a fait travailler qui
l'emmenait sur des tournages qui lui à
qui le recevait
nicolas pernikoff se confiant il n'avait
pas envie c'est moi d'ailleurs pas
comparer à moi mais j'imagine qu'on n'a
pas forcément envie de procédure contre
le fils de sa soeur
est ce que est ce qu'il a essayé de
joindre sa soeur ou olivier ogéron loin
aucune idée sûrement danseurs sa soeur
oui qu'il doit pâlir mans et qu'est-ce
qu'il l'aurait perdu là exactement ce
qui s'est passé mais ils se sont parlés
là depuis depuis aujourd'hui je peux pas
faire elle lui a parlé elle
d'accord mais lui est atterrée par ce
que vous lirez une interview de sa soeur
elle va même plus loin qu olivier
marc-olivier dire que gérard lui
finalement n'a rien fait du tout mais
qu' il aurait laissé faire oui c'est ce
qu'il y est allé encore plus loin elle
que son propre fils que olivier en
disant des choses qui ne sont jamais
arrivées du tout puisque même son fils
le dis même pas alors on sait on ne sait
même plus monde et oui celle qu'utilise
la terre alors ajoute ça semble si elle
pense que peut-être tous les homosexuels
sont pédophiles ce qu est une comme une
erreur grossière
voilà il ya eu aujourd'hui notoire que
gérard louvin n'est pas hétérosexuels et
homosexuels
il ne fait pas de lui pour autant un
pédophile géraldine maillet non alors
évidemment la présomption d'innocence
avant avant toute chose mais malgré tout
moi je pense ce soir aussi à des
personnes qui regardent peut-être cette
émission et qui sont elles victimes
d'inceste pour deux vrilles sûr et je
trouve que vous balayer quand même la
gym c'est qu'elle agisse nommé certain
mais justement il ya aussi des choses
dans les dents ceux qui sont victimes
d'inceste et dans le livre justement sur
la sphère duhamel e kouchner on en parle
très très bien c'est les amnésies
traumatique vous avez raison et dire
qu'on peut être sous emprise
ce serait très bien travailler avec
quelqu'un parce que justement cette que
cette personne représente le pouvoir la
confiance vous dites que cette personne
est fragile par ailleurs pourquoi
est-elle fragile pourquoi est-elle
toxicomanes c'est quoi son parcours
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors certains
d'entre eux disant man avait été victime
d'un énorme changer non absolument mais
je ne fais pas d'amalgamé jusqu'entre
peut-être quand il s'est passé des
choses dans sa vie qui aussi aujourd'hui
expliquerait cette fragilité là donc on
voit la présomption d'innocence
évidemment bien sûr et ce tribunal
médiatique et très violent j'imagine
mais malgré tout il faut aussi penser
qu'elle est gentille ensuite c'est ça
adina raison de préciser sachons raison
victimes
bien sûr nous rejoint sur un élément
vous parler d' amnésie traumatique mais
dans les autres affaires il ya une
amnésie traumatique mais lui il s'est
quand même cédé fait ça fait 10 ça fait
cinq six ans intermittent a fait samedi
6 ans qu'il reproche c'est fait mais
après on ne peut pas vraiment parler de
l'anosy traumatique aujourd'hui on peut
pas en parler aujourd'hui ça tient pas
là oui chacun réagit bon c'est pas parce
que vous avez des amis et traumatique ça
existe que finalement tout le monde dans
ces cas là doit être victime à tout prix
non mais absolue c'est il faut aussi
pouvoir avait raison et d'avoir de
discernement et faire un peu la nappe en
défense et vous dire dans les affaires
qu'on a au cabinet on est le plus
souvent du côté des victimes
bien sûr évidemment mais quand on agit
dans ce genre d'affaires on sait les
risques on en cours bien sûr vous pensez
bien qu'on a pris nos précautions je dis
pas que déjà tout le monde a droit
d'être défendu c'est pas vraiment le
débat mais c'est des affaires dans
lesquelles faut prendre des précautions
et fois quand même arrêter avec cette
sacro sainte parole de la victime
lorsque la victime on part d'un article
qui s'appelle une vie brisée mais la vie
qu'on est en train de briser
c'est celle de gérard louvin et celle de
daniel moyne